bonjour jean marc sylvestre vous
retrouver dans la matinale berthet
france alors très précisément quelle est
la facture du quoi qu'il en coûte qu'est
ce qui vous fait penser que l'état ne va
pas véritablement débrancher toutes les
perfusions
bas vous savez la facture est très
lourde on s'en doutait alors la mise
l'économie bruno le maire déclare vous
vous lavez vous l'avez cité et on a
entendu que le quoi qu'il en coûte est
terminée parce qu'il constate que
l'économie va mieux et c'est vrai
qu'elle se redresse au fur et à mesure
que le pays ne se sent de moins en moins
menacé par la pandémie on devrait donc
retrouver un niveau d'activité normale à
la fin de l'année dans ces conditions
paraît logique que ministre annonce la
fin d'un certain nombre d' aide aux
futures à mesure donc que le travail va
reprendre on ne peut pas imaginer
économie sous perfusion tout le temps
doux l'annnonce du recul de deux fonds
de solidarité du remboursement ou du
début d'un remboursement des dpe et puis
aussi un recul des allocations de
chômage partiel alors trois choses quand
même très très très vite 1 il est
évident que ce poids qu'il en coûte a
permis de protéger le système économique
il a permis d'éviter une catastrophe
presque tous les chefs d'entreprise le
reconnaissent là mais deuxième point
c'est vrai il a coûté très cher mais ça
un bruno le maire dit que la facture
représente 240 milliards d'euros bah
c'est 10 % de la richesse nationale
alors dans ses 240 milliards d'euros
vous avez quoi vous avez un les 160
milliards de prêts aux entreprises dont
une partie c'est vrai va être remboursée
mais vous avez surtout les 80 milliards
de dhs exonérations de charges sociales
vous avez le chul à l'allocation chômage
et le fonds de solidarité aux
entreprises c'est un peu l'allocation
chômage et le fonctionnement hérité on
va commencer à raboter en premier alors
c'est une facture provisoire sahin vous
avez de l'argent qui va revenir sur les
prêts par exemple il faut espérer que
les entreprises vont réussir à
rembourser une grande partie mais vous
avez des dépenses qui ne sont pas
comptabilisés les recettes fiscales ne
sont pas rentrés parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup moins d'activité donc moins
d'impôts moins de tva ça représente
quand même 37 milliards sur 2020 bono on
n'a pas beaucoup parlé de ça et
vraisemblablement 20 milliards de perdus
en 2021 donc la facture sera plus lourde
que ce que le ministre a annoncées
j'ajoute qu'on va en plus forcément
continuer à injecter de l'argent alors
justement combien l'état va-t-il encore
dépensé et pour quoi alors alors là on
n'a pas de détails là mais c'est quand
même un simple calcul est d'abord un on
a un plan de relance et d'investissement
qui va sortir cet automne je crois qu
emmanuel macron doit se prononcer là
dessus dans l'est dans les deux semaines
qui viennent ça va coûter 20 à 30
milliards c'est la part française parce
qu'il ya une autre partie qui sera payé
par le budget européen c'est là dessus
que le président a accueilli qui va nous
donner un certain nombre de précisions
mais on a aussi le lancement du revenu
universel pour les jeunes ça va coûter 3
milliards par an vous avez également la
facture du ségur de la santé ce qui
avait été négocié la dernière ça va
représenter cette année 12 milliards ça
représentera également 12 milliards
l'année prochaine et puis vous allez
avoir les dépenses ministérielles qui
seront inscrits au budget l'intérieur la
justice l'éducation
ils ont tous ses ministères ont déjà
reçu la promesse de rallonge et puis on
va continuer à soutenir certaines
activités qui étaient en difficulté
avant et qui ont été abîmés par la crise
on ne laissera pas tomber c'est vrai que
l'événementiel le tourisme sont dans des
situations très difficiles très
compliqué réunion des partenaires
sociaux aujourd'hui à matignon auprès du
premier ministre pour discuter de cet
environnement là et du chantier de
réformes en cours on n'a pas oublié
celui des retraites celui du chômage
dont la mise en oeuvre est un peu
reculés ou totalement recul et c'est là
dessus qu'il va falloir vieux la statue
est donc vous voyez en valais c'est
quand même le quoi qu'il en coûte très
très très en vue il ya un très prêt à
fonctionner qui va payer ah ouais alors
ça c'est la question qu'on prouve par a
on ne la pose pas parce que on a on est
à quelques mois des élections
présidentielles alors je crois que ça
ferait désordre je pense que le
gouvernement a fait 3 paris le premier
c'est le pari d'une reprise très forte
et d'une croissance il parle de 6 7%
pour 17 années donc ça ça permettrait de
drainer des recettes fiscales
supplémentaires donc le deuxième baril
c'est le plan d'une solidarité
européenne pour abandonner le dogme de
la rigueur maastricht yen alors sa
rivale vaincre on va en parler puis vous
savez qui prend la présidence de
l'europe au début de l'année prochaine
et à ce moment-là ça permettra
éventuellement de lui donner un peu de
marge d'initiative et puis le troisième
paris c'est le pari peut-être d'une
inflation contrôler site une grosse
inconnue l'inflation on aurait besoin
d'inflation mais pas trop sinon les taux
d'intérêts remonter si les taux
d'intérêt remontent et bien la dette
coûte plus cher alors qu'actuellement la
dette ne coûte pas cher elle rapporte
même de l'argent alors pour répondre
très cash à votre question on ne parlera
pas d'impôts avant les élections
présidentielles de l'année prochaine et
oui évidemment merci beaucoup jean marc
sylvestre pour votre analyse vous
parliez d'un de la rentrée sociale on va
en parler tout de suite